couchée dans ma chambre d'étudiant
j'avais le sentiment que tout le monde
est en train de s'écrouler mes rêves mes
projets mais aspirations balayé du
revers de la main en quelques secondes
à cette époque j'avais 19 ans et j'ai
tâché de pointe fédération
voyez vous je suis issu d'une famille
modeste son père était fonctionnaire et
ma mère également et toute ma vie nous
on éduque et avec beaucoup d'amour e
d'école nous permettrait de pouvoir
réussi notre fille et ma mère n'a pas
les musulmans
lorsque mes amis joie foule
je passais mon temps à la bibliothèque
pendant les vacances je préparais
l'année suivante et chaque jour tous qui
concourait concourir injustement à nous
permettre d'avancer dans l'étude
nos parents mes parents mais d'un seul à
ma disposition pour les silos du bien
évidemment pas là ce type d'éducation en
avance très vite j'ai donc fait un
parcours sans faute et en soir à table
parce que j'étais en sixième ne m'a même
à notre avis des passants concours dans
deux semaines le jour le jour de
l'examen du concours se sont enfuis
déclame un que je découvre que je suis
en train de passer le comment de l'école
mi-septembre technique de bingerville un
groupe très difficile pour entrer dans
les cols prestigieux quotidien mais je
fais ce qu'il faut et si mon frère sur
six à sept écoles intègrent donc cette
école prestigieuse et vous savez dans la
main ces conditions l'information
on n'a pas le droit de rêver à la pipe
ce condiment de fès est la même avec
visa parce qu'avec la chicotte croire
obligé d'obéir pour nous parler du
problème est donc là bas également
j'obéis aux autres et j'avance j'avance
j'avance jusqu'au second terminal où
j'ai de bonnes moyennes et ne sont
inscrits sur une liste provisoire
d'élèves pour bénéficier de pause
d'études poignée dans les rues la cité
militaire des plus prestigieux du monde
sur eux
j'obtiens mon bac et l'état de
côte-d'ivoire par m'oriente une filière
des deux criées les nouvelles
technologies une filiale informatique et
une fillette n'avait pas franchement
demandé et comme j'avais un imprimé un
tempo en exécutant déjà depuis tout
l'été avec mes parents et ensuite à
l'école militaire
j'accepte et je gêne dans cette école là
dessus a augmenté avec un ami un
collègue d'abord qui aujourd'hui est
devenu un ami comme un frère est
ensemble on commence la première année
après six mois nous sommes toujours dans
l'attenté de la ligue des étudiants
devant bénéficier des bourses d'études
puis un jour dans son impulsion de
lewiston la défense qui montrera que les
sélectionnés
croyez moi pour moi c'est une bonne
issue d'une famille modeste comédie
poteau j'avais la possibilité d'intégrer
une école internationale d'avoir un
parcours militaire devait officier de
l'armée
avec tout ce qui va avec j'étais très
vite j'ai formé proches et se joue là
comment l'appel on me demande de venir
alors vous faites allusion afin de
remplir les formalités bien sûr tous les
étudiants du théâtre donne ce coup de
fil et j'avais eu la chance de voir deux
ans quand j'ai fait mon ami avec qui je
suis je demande ma compagne et les huit
ans et il était un peu triste parce que
par lui aussi de revient du poids lourds
y fier de cela
j'insiste j'insiste je suis tu parce que
moi aussi simple à sa place à six parce
que je suis dit que peut-être que si ma
compagne et il aurait l'opportunité
pourquoi pas de bénéficier d'une autre
bossou devant veut pas faire le procès
bref
j'espérais quelque chose pour lui parce
que c'était mon amour et donc nous voilà
le film parle comme un crétin le mot là
dessus tous deux en route pour le volet
la défense avions militaires en compte à
personne chargée les causes de la faim
dit pépé paul ii reçoit mais documents
devant moi et commence à me james qui
transfère je pourrais difficilement à
cacher ma joie
donc ils m'expliquent ans fermes
explique que une école qui est maroc
l'académie militaire royale et puis elle
nous donne tous les détails et
qu'ensuite il ya une petite allée tout
ce qui va nous puis avant faire
attention à mon avis les gîtes derrière
moi l appel il vient et elle lui demande
de se présenter à bagdad a reçu dans mon
ami se prétend s'appeler qui sèche alors
sa suppléante est si dense dans la salle
après quelques moments d'hésitation
l'officier chargé des routes ou regarder
mais qui en fait cette année peut-être
préféré c'est difficile de pau à choisir
et nous allons crier pas choisir mais
lorsque l'on regarde les moyennes en
fait ces dix sièges qui doit bénéficier
de la bourse il était devant pas de zéro
+0 5 point
et comme on n'arrivait pas à le joindre
plusieurs semaines avec le comité
on avait décidé de s'accorder la bourse
maintenant qui est là bas j'ai le devoir
moral de victimes qui a dit que vous
croyez moi un peu avoir en fait la vie
sur un plateau d'argent
la vie peut nous servir un plateau
d'argent toutes les opportunités mais
rien n'est jamais acquis
bien sûr un des costumes décors office
pas si c'est la fête à traiter la bourse
et c'est ainsi que je me suis trouvé de
se retrouver dans la champ et pendant
trois semaines
si vous voulez le voir un peu de recul
aux livres mais moi à sa place
et pas sûr que je vais et je tenais j'en
suis à mes paroles parce que toute ma
vie ma 20 tandis youn et % fallait
travailler dur pour réussi à l'école
pour faire de grandes choses et ces gens
voulaient hamelin cadre musique parce
que j'ai des bonnes notes à l'école et
je méditais cela ils m'ont demandé de
faire ça j'ai un parcours sans faute
j'ai jamais été punis ch dans la sphère
que sont l'école militaire est
aujourd'hui sur les 2 5 pouces gens
venaient en route et j'ai passé trois
semaines comme ça enfermé dans la
chambre
moyennant brillant notre foi qui était
devenu un élément violent
d'ailleurs j'étais parti à l'école
pendant ces trois semaines j'ai raté
tout m'était clame m et j'étais juste en
bref relents dans une presque
puis un soir chez la même chambre sur
l'autre un coup tu veux dire que depuis
ce qui suit je n'ai pas trop décroché l
appel parce que et donc je reçois un
bouchon s'était glissée âge tu me
parlais d'un langage propre à nous que
tu crois ils me disent on a le regard
comment tu vas à son avis je suis dans
l'avion et je tenais véritablement à
toutes ignorées
parce que les jab angevin du monde pour
d'imoko institut aux fans la côte
d'ivoire et j'avais jamais imaginé que
je prendrai l'avion aidera fatwa du si
aujourd'hui la a dit prêt à décoller ou
une nouvelle invention
si tu n'avais pas une cité je serais pas
parti
elle c'est pourquoi m parce que tu aimes
les autres parce que nous étions en
forme depuis toutes les années mais ce
jour là
peut-être parce que je demande la fronti
dans mon regard que j'avais mal principe
est que je vienne aujourd'hui je suis là
ne sait pas que demain nous réserve mais
je connais des capacités vous est ce que
tu veux et si ça tapait la vidéo tu
donneras une seconde chance afin de
montrer au monde ce que tu vaux ne
décourage pas
et là on a conscience de la tour en
sorte d'en douter de ce que vous payez
par téléphone les grandes à partir mais
dès qu'on tend la parenthèse nazie belge
je me souviens nation est manifestement
ivre une fois que ces boutons vie un peu
de jus avec la solution
bref on a bien vu mais après son appel
j'étais totalement son appel a
cruellement processus d'échauffement et
équitable j'ai pas dormi mais nous si on
dit content de ma vie j'avais écrit les
zones visitées à ma place
savio qu'une lente et les parents
d'ailleurs je suis fier d'avoir mené un
moment si tu le regardes tu fais la
bonne humeur comme ça qui nous a poussé
malgré le fait qu'un épisode n'est pas
fait de la musique nous a poussés à
travailler parfois la débile travaille
bien mais j'avais pas de volonté et donc
je faisais tout pouvait pas avoir de
problème et pour justement consulter les
autres mais quelques mois je vous fais
peur et se joue là qui a décidé de
reprendre ma vie en main et j'avais de
visu au lendemain matin gérard bastide à
manger mais ma femme j'ai rangé ma
chambre
derrière l'état et se retourne en commun
la première chose que j'ai faite de
l'inscrire au deuxième session a enfin
quitté toulouse
ce que j'ai fait et cette phrase me
demandais ce que je voulais faire je
viens a pris facilement déterminer chose
que je voulais faire donc finalement le
son du bal que j'étais c'est le
marketing les faits le management de la
communication et toutes ces choses à me
passionner donc d'une part le travail
est due à l'école m'a prêté en
informatique et en réalité jalma choisir
avait imposé et d'autres pages commencé
à travailler très dur me suis dit qu'on
fait un fil des courants de vie qui
comme on dit la chiquenaude qu'un qui
parle et de marketing malade m j'ai
commencé à marcher avec des gens que
notre fille bien là et je prenais leur
courroux leurs cahiers et c'est parti ça
m'a passionné
je me disais que même si je rate ma vie
au moins je veux pouvoir faire ce que
j'aime comme ça peu importe qui va
arriver je réussis heureuse et donc et
d'autre part vous savez de maintenir
très bonne et chromatisme fois que j'ai
à croire en ce que tu fais fort
justement de mettre à la place des
clients fait d'imaginer des solutions
qui te permettront pourquoi pas plus
tard
bart dalton d'abord de créer de
l'innovation degré du changement des
tracteurs des changements quand je
travaillais comme ça j'arrête de
regarder les filles y ont vu un ministre
vient l'été toute discussion que nous ne
démontre pas d'aller vers mon objectif
j'ai commencé à marcher mais je pourrais
me propulser 20 dans l'objectif j'avais
19 ans après j'ai l'intention paraît de
nature
mais j'avais une certaine manière de
pensée qui nous permettait d'avancer
davantage
et puis joue annonce que dans trois
jours il ya un an plus tard c'est de
préparer comme je peux et on arrive au
jour j tout de suite au total le design
chez les poussines quotes parts mais le
tamani techno rock et l'entretien de
certaines tueries 15 minutes
ce jour là en fait 45 minutes elle afin
d'aider choisi comme la comptable
informatique de cette entreprise basée à
vienne
il avait un sentiment les capacités et
voilà estimant à près du mans boulet
pour
tableau cas au maroc au canada afin de
mettre en place la filiale de cette
entreprise en top echirolles
pour moi c'était totalement l'espace le
début d'une très belle aventure
entrepreneuriale qui m'a conduit en
afrique du sud en belgique en france et
au maroc
alors j'ai pas de leçon à donner mais de
cette expérience là j'ai tiré beaucoup
d'enseignements
déjà parce que jamais 21 au cg
aujourd'hui de maître d'oeuvre 19 ans
j'étais jeune et jolie j'allais venir
est donc très g9 sentiment d'échec
pierre de chignac de me lever et donc
j'estime que c'est quelque chose d'assez
quelque chose à partager donc de tous et
si je retiens trois choses
nous avons le pouvoir des crimes nommé
porte voix toute ma vie j'avais laisser
les autres décider à ma place les
parents l'armée l'état pendant
d'étiquetage
et adresses des chefs j'avais décidé de
prendre ma vie en main
j'avais décidé de faire quelque chose
j'avais décidé de passer à l'action et
des climats nos bonnes histoires chacun
de nous a le droit du sol histoire
l'école les parents nous oriente le clic
l'école nous montre une voie que c'est
une voix parmi d'une même voix et chaque
d'une érosion à chacun de nous de
prendre la diffusion de prendre sa vie
en main et décline son histoire deuxième
point et voit l'affairé semble donc voir
ce que donne dans le nord a dit jeudi
pas la chance
les directs plutôt la réussite qu'on a
vu contre entre la préparation
l'opportunité je ne savais pas quand
est-ce que de continuer ce programme
mais j'avais décidé de nous préparer et
lorsque j'ai décidé de commencer à
prendre des coups de marketing
l'extérieur ce n'est pas jean rède ne
savais même pas finir je voudrais
l'achat de points devant quelqu'un afin
de lui parler de ça mais ça me
passionnait et j'ai commencé à me
préparer et croyez moi cette préparation
a tué un iphone et un peu plus que tous
les jeux viennent des environs
et lorsque l'opportunité s'est présentée
et du aviez donc fuyez doit diffuser et
enfin l'action tu as peur tu aimes tu es
le thème de mon intervention
l'action tu l'acteur va de soi et dès
que nous traversons quel que soit le
problème que nous avons en tout temps en
tout lieu et en toute circonstance
il faut agir reste à coucher enfermé
dans mission maraîchage
les ventes ont pâti lorsqu'on phénomène
se passe d'ailleurs une veine des murs
du doubs favorable et j5 différentes
dispose il faut agi parce que l'action
du laveur lost on plante le phoning
vingtaine qui est demain entre nos mains
c'est sûr qu'il va mourir et cela qu'on
décide de la plante et il ya des
opportunités il ya au moins une chance
même si on milliards qu'elles
grandissent et deviennent 80
et lorsqu'on ne fait rien ne se passe
enfin la vie n'aurait pas permis de
pouvoir avoir le bonheur dont on me
parle et dont mes parents ne parlait
dans l'armée ne parlait alors j'ai
décidé de le créer
alors la question que j'ai à vous poser
ce soir puis vous avez l'opportunité
simone qui est un don vous en étiez
l'auteur
qu'est ce que vous faisiez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à